what is up how's it going Pepe here
we're playing part two of South Park the
fraction butthole it's so fun so far I'm
loving it and thank you guys so much for
all the love the support in the first
video
yes we did it we just picked our
superhero
he looks look at him he's got that oh my
god everyone say I look at like him guy
or whatever my flaming [ __ ] brother hell
yeah we picked the right character
that's for shizzle we picked the right
character look at it goddamn beautiful
Koons to Graham okay guys let me know if
if any time scrambles out of there okay
fine you're the mayor's aides say she's
too busy to worry about the cat what I
can't read I'm in literate hey she's
took away the lava hold l2 to find
people to take selfies with for
Instagram you can take selfies with
people that have a camera icon above
their heads okay to regress a selfie
approach someone and press r1 okay let's
get out of the picture here what mood do
we want I was something i zoom in on her
tits or something
there it is we got a new follower sure
we're an influencer Instagram miss for
nickel is now a follower only people who
pose in yourself will follow you it's
basically follow follow for follow press
to see who you are following
okay we're following her as well yeah
we're one of these lame celebrities that
just follow everyone to get followers
all right we need more respect
we need more street cred I get it let's
go this way you want to take a selfie no
no let's go and take a selfie with
butters dad that's not we're good right
hey buddy
oh why we can add a filter why is this a
thing I guess we got to take more
selfies level up our influence this is
just like real life I really they really
breached the gap finally it's not a
sword can I know okay he's gonna want to
take a selfie then shut your why does no
one want to take a selfie with me it's
just like we're laughs damn it oh that
she Pokemon chip oak I love that episode
the classic all right you did it
that doesn't look weird at all
ah bless did I not do it I don't
understand r1 you help me with this
thing it's stuck okay we got to help him
first stuck there you go you just punch
it with some dumb little Superman the
real deal let's take a selfie
sure let's do it this is so lame
whatever I so - you can why Cartman okay
okay nice now thank you
god damn yeah when you have two
followers that's that's when you know
you really hit those we're friends now I
guess take this stupid self face
yes shut up let's check the map Google
Maps
can't seem to forget it there we go
alright l1 are available mission okay
talk to super Craig okay let's do like
that and then we have the mini-map okay
cool we literally just have to walk to
the left
so let's do that Baby Bop a pretty peppy
room ah the classic ah the nostalgia
we're gonna fight why don't you make me
[Laughter]
yeah no I did it I literally just did it
[Music]
stop this at once
yeah just don't Stan begin
he's grossed out okay alright let's kick
this guy's ass wow you are so brave
let's go let's go
I may have missed one of them my turn
now
[ __ ] come on oh not a whip press X
turning attack okay
he's both grossed out and burning this
should be a cake in the park walk in the
cake please don't die nuke it thank you
thank you very much ah that one doesn't
do that much I don't know why I use this
one but whatever
got'em I think we can just literally
punch it we won we did it everyone and
we got a clump of cat hair that's truly
a reward worthy of a superhero of our
status I really liked Scott I'm glad we
picked this one keep it up Ethan proud
of you
Wow okay now give me max let's take a
stupid selfie you really want a selfie
with me not really but I need Kunz to
grandfather mercy why don't you defeat
that sixth grader with so cool just stop
talking stop talking thank you hi guys
what's up
don't mind me just looting your house
help Jimmy finish up his big project in
sure now take yourself oh this is so
lame fine fine Jimmy are you up here can
you use that oh he has a handicap toilet
all right we found some good [ __ ] should
we take a [ __ ] it's been a while I know
this is a difficult one there it is
oh it's tricky ah yeah okay
Jeremiah oh god it's tricky is tricky
ah no uh no little release that was a
hard one man I'm loving this game so far
he completely uneventful mm-hmm
so dope
I just want to explore everything that
doesn't really happen for me in games
usually people get pissed off at me it's
definitely something new oh yeah I even
forgot our quest was to find super crane
there we go oh my controller got stuck
we have crafting can we punch this as
what no those explosive might be useful
later but for now let's check out super
Krang I'm sorry but I cannot assist
anyone with their problems right now
super Kraig can't fight his guinea pig
oh the coud that I'm not playing until I
find stripe he's not just adorable
guinea pig he belongs to B and my
ex-boyfriend that's right super craig is
gay I'll bet stripe is down to the
basement again we should start at the
basement that's the last place I saw
Craig and tweek
wasn't it I think it may be he smelled
the dog food all rights in the basement
let's find him well dad by the stairs
that keep him from escaping you do the
rest butthole be careful snap and pops
on line
oh those might be handy you're welcome
you're welcome thank you
I can we pass oh well luckily oh I
second okay oh my god I'm gonna kill him
aren't I oh thank god he's the life come
on oh my god oh oh no oh no oh I'll
figure out his alive I'm just glad he's
alive how
oh I dragged it right Wow can you stop I
killed it now didn't aim what do I eat
for these farts man oh I used that me
guinea pig it was she I had to one was
called cheese and the other one was
named after me if it was called feed
left field is like a nickname for Felix
in Sweden it's so dumb alright let's
take a shopping on Coons to Graham okay
I don't know why I'm doing this but we
did it got a level up that influence of
dog new kid yeah what up hey there oh
you want a Craig's friends you're
looking for Craig no me
let's just say I'm an art collector now
what is happening flea modern an
extremely confusing Asian art for what
crazy right but this stuff is worth a
fortune to the right buyer if in your
adventures you find any of these bring
them to me it is so messed up
come back with any new pieces you find
rain kids better appreciate this goddamn
thing oh wow
okay alright they went there huh that's
cool so you can actually find more of
the art Craig and tweek I ship them so
hard they were on point with that
episode I was like damn that's [ __ ]
awesome
alright no drone zone can you use drones
later then okay so we have the snaps now
so maybe we can try it out like oh wow
we did a baddy I feel like oh should we
stay or oh I see I see I see there you
go a recipe oh cool so we can get a new
outfit that's awesome alright don't how
you doing there buddy
oh here you don't look like one of
Henrietta's chums hey the game looks so
good it really feels like you're playing
interesting get up you one of those free
range kids okay buddy
it really feels like you're playing some
intense crunch did you guys ever play
that old the softball game on Nintendo
64 that was so fun all those turkeys
that you had to kill in that game my god
we forgot here as well maybe we should
try it just for fun
okay then I'm out of ideas let's check
our customs okay power source Anil
great okay what do we got crap thing
okay so you can craft anyway so came a
craft ik we need crafter rank seven okay
we can craft some revived serum that
seems pretty good let's do that maybe
that will help us level up a bit as well
okay we need to find more stuff because
I want to make that outfit that looks
coal consumables we don't have to check
let's I want to check like our missions
meet Kyle at his house pin it and let's
go oh my god you dad it's Lego oh my
cute ants what fam em hey you want to
take a selfie girl
hey what up what in the world
okay can we our okay let's not do that
it is actual lava how about that DLC
alright let's just ignore these guys for
now probably you have to fight them to
keep going later in the area this is so
dope sorry by hitting that by accident
is the most annoying [ __ ] hey kid you
know anything about this somebody's
keying my wife's car it's happening
every night I thought it was just one of
you damn kids but wolf here come here
take a look at this
get on Randy one of my favorite
characters matching the car is also
leaving notes I'm just scared it's
jilted lover or something you won't
forget me that easy I thought we had
something I'll tell the world about you
[ __ ] listen I'm sick of having to puff
this [ __ ] out if you can catch whoever's
keying my wife's car tonight
I'll follow you on Instagram okay you
want me as a phone I'm a pretty big deal
instead this is a side quest I'm happy
to do it
cuz I mean he's a pretty big deal right
plus we are playing on 'hardest
difficulty
yeah let's go in here should we
all right there yes how are you
it's a me sorry kid but my problem is
too big for a rookie a few days ago
there was an anomaly in the universe
another version of me the human kite
from an alternate dimension showed up
here and is destroying everything
right now it's upstairs in my room I
don't think anything can stop it go to
cow's room okay you look so weird human
kite from another universe is behind
this door I can't fight it for obvious
reasons you know alternative universe
paradox [ __ ] so you are going to have to
take him out yeah I want to fight dude
so that he wants to return back to his
universe on the 8th go who is this gonna
be who is it the human kites him from a
universe he's the one running around
giving to him a kite a bad name he was
sent here to destroy me and weaken my
house no no I came to spend two weeks
with my cousin and wanted to play
superhero I remember this episode but
super here do you want to be and I said
I want to be human kite but he said you
can't be human kite I'm you mean kite
and I said well why can't we be human
kites together so I went to aunt Sheila
and I said I want to be human
I was the guest he needs to die this man
you mean me
I'm sorry me from another universe but
it is time for you to learn that playing
superheroes is too painful new kid you
must now destroy my alter-ego
100% if you really want this how you do
it well alright anything to make me and
my cousin more like they called me a
weakling you called me a weakly yes oh
I'm afraid that's impossible I didn't
bring my pigs alright let's just destroy
him
we can beat him if we join Boise's yeah
I really want to my parallel universe
will say I can't I keep missing it I
need to learn how to do it properly
well you're literally on fire I'm sxi
whatever
alright time for another tech I guess we
can just I want to do it okay I'll do it
next
okay what can't pull [ __ ] like that
oh my god
you're so annoying okay I hit it too
early that's what I'm doing no stop I
hate you
okay has protection indicated by the
blue bar okay yeah fine whatever
preferably prescription-strength but I
should go beyond the screen okay let's
use another attack so I think it should
be I don't want to cause any from any
damage I want you to burn
okay you don't burn watch me do it
properly this time and seem to get it oh
my god yes I'm ready
oh wow he's doing it he's beginning to
believe yes yeah hey we got the Hawkeye
mass nice and we level up how about that
I hope you did oh you're leaving dude
that sucks yeah going back to that
universe now human kite I need some came
to Phoenix for my ear because I got a
scrape on it baby farted on dude I don't
know how to thank you from now on
ecology whatever you need help this is
st. this is it guys
selfie let's do it selfie time heck yeah
nice okay let's go down that was awesome
okay so why do you get so quiet now we
can find yah we in South LA
hey remember that
[Music]
all right let's go back to the [ __ ] lair
which of course is right next to us
[Music]
the cuny oh it's in the basement my bed
so I have to enter the code again
amazing my sorry mom you pee mom sorry
[ __ ] you mom
so dumb being a superhero is a little
harder than you thought huh
yep it's okay no totally suck but I
can't help but feel sorry for you
because your dad this way I'm gonna
teach you about artifacts you see most
superheroes augment their abilities with
specialized equipment
[Music]
you'll find things like these out of its
ham the trick is to equip them into your
artifacts [ __ ] go on get this what in
the world okay every artifact has a
specific place it can be slotted on your
body uh-huh
equip this one to boost your strength
stats
did it it might be a little
uncomfortable at first your DNA is
fusing with it you'll find more other
facts out there doing your superhero
adventures we can even craft your own
just remember great power comes great
bat sir I think you're ready to take on
those sixth graders now oh hell yeah but
Lord is going let's do this I'm ready
we could do there Randy quest as well I
just don't know how we doesn't need to
find who did it what we can also do it
later
what is this oh now we can fast travel
thanks to okay
activate the Mainstreet fast okay nice
we should fart on them before we find
him Meredith let's do this oh we can
help Austin let's try mastermind I don't
think it'll be that difficult so we can
actually start with here we go oh this
might be difficult they do a lot of
events oh nice it's pretty big damn they
do a lot of damage oh you did not just
say that
can you guys tank some damage can you
give burritos to other people I don't
think so I don't know what Cal can do
okay that's a long range you can heal
okay let's do that and then he can
Craig's blocking paralyzes him to
deflect damage okay doesn't do any
damage at all
I don't know why that was let's eat this
burrito as well
[Music]
why am i gross that was it a disgusting
burrito okay cool let's see what happens
then nice oh my god that is alive we
almost have our super though okay oh no
no no seriously
oh I see okay we can only be here
I'm really trying hard here guys there's
only one guy in left okay now it's time
to use it yes yes
[Music]
come on it didn't do that much damage oh
wow he does a lot image here we go
there it is I went over gear yeah that's
what's right that's what's good done
diddle mastermind I probably won't do
more mastermind just because I took way
too long let's go
but before we go I have to end this
episode here I'll make it super long
episode tomorrow if you guys keep
showing your support with likes and
comments and all that [ __ ] really
appreciate you guys I'm having so much
fun thank you guys I really mean it see
you tomorrow
squad fam brofist